♪
♪ YOU.
AINSLEY: A BORDER TOWN IN
ARIZONA IS UNDER A STATE OF
EMERGENCY DUE TO THE MIGRANT
SURGE.
TOMI LAHREN MET WITH THE MAYOR
OF GILL LA BEND WHO IS BLAMING
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION FOR
SENDING MIGRANTS TO HIS TOWN BY
BUS.
>> I NEVER HAD DROPS HERE BEFORE
NEVER DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OR OBAMA-BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
I HAVE NEVER HAD DROPS HERE.
I’M SEEING BORDER PATROL
BRINGING PEOPLE HERE AND DROP
THEM OFF.
30 MILES TO THE NEXT TOWN OPEN
DESSERT.
GOING TO WALK PEOPLE OVER THAT
DESSERT 120 DEGREES YOU WILL
FIND A LOT OF BODIES.
>> THEY’RE SAYING IT’S NOT
UNPRECEDENTED IT’S HAPPENED
BEFORE.
>> I DON’T WANT TO PLAY POLITICS
BUT THIS IS A CRISIS PURE AND
SIMPLE.
AINSLEY: TOMI JOINS US NOW WITH
MORE.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, TOMI.
>> GOOD MORNING, YEAH.
YOU KNOW, IT’S AMAZING WHEN YOU
ACTUALLY GO TO THESE TOWNS AND
ACTUALLY SPEAK TO THESE MAYORS
AND SPEAK TO THESE LAND OWNERS
THEY ARE TELLING YOU THIS IS A
CRISIS AND THEY FEEL LARGELY
IGNORED.
BUT, YOU KNOW, KAMALA HARRIS,
SHE HASN’T GONE DOWN.
SHE HASN’T DONE WHAT I HAVE
DONE.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU AFTER
SPENDING A COUPLE DAYS WITH
THESE FOLKS IT IS A CRISIS.
IT IS UNPRECEDENTED AND
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE.
AINSLEY: SO QUHINDZ OF STORIES?
WHAT DID YOU HEAR FROM THESE
RANCHERS DOWN THERE?
>> YOU KNOW, I SPOKE TO ONE
RANCHER AND PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN
BORDER TOWNS, ESPECIALLY
RANCHERS IN BORDER TOWNS THEY
ARE USED TO HAVING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND MIGRANTS COME
ACROSS THEIR PROPERTY.
WHAT THEY ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW
IS UNPRECEDENTED BECAUSE THOSE
COMING ACROSS, THEY ARE COMING
ACROSS BRAZENLY.
THEY ARE COMING ACROSS AS THOUGH
THEY HAVE BEEN INVITED.
SOME OF THE THINGS THEY ARE
FINDING AND SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY’RE COMING IN CONTACT
WITH.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
UNAPOLOGETIC ABOUT WHY THEY ARE
COMING OVER.
THEY FEEL IT’S THEIR RIGHT TO
COME OVER AND FEEL THEY HAVE
BEEN INVITED.
IT’S NOT GOING TO STOP ANY TIME
SOON.
YOU HALT IN BORDER WALL
CONSTRUCTION WITH THE MESSAGE
COMING FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
THE FIVE MILE GAP OF THIS
RANCHER IN PARTICULAR IS HAVING
TO DEAL WITH AND ADD IN ALL
THOSE OTHER POLICIES LIKE TAKING
AWAY REMAIN IN MEXICO AND YOU
HAVE GOT THE PERFECT STORM FOR A
WHOLE LOT OF PROBLEMS AT THE
BORDER.
AINSLEY: WE HAVE A CLIP OF ONE
OF THE RANCHERS YOU TALKED TO IN
NOGALES, LISTEN TO THIS.
>> WE FIND THIS QUITE OFTEN AND
THE CARPET BOOTIES ARE USED TO
CONCEAL THE FOOTPRINTS.
MAKE IT HARDER FOR THE AGENTS TO
TRACK.
>> BECAUSE THEY WILL SCUFF OUT
THEIR OWN TRACKS?
>> THIS IS AN EXACT OF THE
CARPET BOOTY.
IT FITS OVER THEIR SHOES.
EVERYBODY THAT’S COMING ACROSS
IS DRESSED IN CAMOUFLAGE.
>> THESE ARE SOLD AS WELL ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THE BORDER.
THESE ARE LIKE MANUFACTURED FOR
PEOPLE.
>> YEP.
AINSLEY: TOMI, ARE THEY SEEING
MORE PANDEMIC ON THEIR
PROPERTIES THAN THEY USED TO.
>> THEY ARE.
BEYOND THAT I WANT PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THIS IS THIS RANCHER
AND OTHER RANCHERS THERE THIS IS
HIS LIVELIHOOD.
HE HAS HAD HIS PROPERTY SET ON
FIRE.
HE HAS HIS FENCES CUT ON A DAILY
BASIS HAVING TO GO AND REPAIR
THEM.
WHEN YOU HAVE A RANCH THAT’S
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF ACRES
AND HAVING TO GO AND SPEND YOUR
TIME REPAIRING FENCE AND WIRING
BECAUSE ILLEGALS ARE CUTTING IT
ON A DAILY BASIS SABOTAGING
WATER SUPPLY AND LIGHTING FIRES
THIS IS SOMETHING THEY ARE
DEALING WITH ON A DAILY BASIS.
NORMALLY THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
CALL BORDER PATROL AND HAVE MORE
OF AN OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS
THESE THINGS WITH BORDER PATROL
AND HAVE A RESPONSE.
BUT BORDER PATROL HAS BEEN SENT
NOW TO THESE PROCESSING AND
DETENTION CENTERS TO DEAL WITH
THE UNACCOMPANIED MINORS COMING
THROUGH SO THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO
RESPOND LIKE THEY USED.
TO SAY THEY ARE REALLY BEING
OVERWORKED.
THEIR RESOURCES ARE LIMITED AND
NOW RANCHERS LIKE THIS ARE
REALLY CONCERNED BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A HALT IN BORDER WALL DOING
AT LOVE THE WORK BEFORE THEY
THOUGHT THIS WOULD SOLVE MANY OF
THE PROBLEMS BUT NOW THEY ARE
LEFT COMPLETELY EXPOSED.
THEY SHOULDN’T BE DEALING WITH
THIS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE’S LIVELIHOODS.
WANT PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND THE
RANCHERS ON THE MEXICAN SIDE
THEY WANT BORDER WALL AND GOOD
POLICIES BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THEY
ARE HAVING SMUGGLERS AND CARTELS
USING THEIR PROPERTY AS A
GO-BETWEEN AND THEY DON’T WANT
THAT EITHER.
THAT’S ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
LIVING AND WORKING THEIR LIVELY
HOOD IS AT STAKE.
THIS SIN DEED A CRISIS FOR SO
MANY.
AINSLEY: OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, TOMI.
NO INTERRUPTION IS ON FOX
NATION.
YOU WILL HAVE TO CHECK IT OUT.
WE HAVE MORE "FOX & FRIENDS"
COMING UP.
FLORIDA’S GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS.